PRESIDENTIAL HISTORY.
SO-CALLED EXPERTS IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAY TRUMP
ISN'T JUST BAD, HE'S THE WORST
PRESIDENT EVER.
BUT FIRST, THE FALLOUT FROM THE
SHOOTING AT A PARKLAND FLORIDA
HIGH SCHOOL WEDNESDAY THAT
KILLED 17 PEOPLE IS TURNING INTO
A STUDENT LED MASSIVE MOVEMENT
AGAINST GUNS.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SIGNALING
HE MAY FAVOR GUN CONTROL
LEGISLATION.
STUDENTS ARE INVOLVED IN THE
PLANNING AT LEAST IN FOUR MAJOR
UPCOMING PROTEST, INCLUDING A
MARCH ON WASHINGTON NEXT MONTH.
PARKLAND, FLORIDA, STUDENTS WHO
SURVIVED LAST WEEK'S SHOOTING
ARE TAKING TO THE AIRWAVES TO
PROMOTE THE NEW CAMPAIGN.
>> THE TRAGEDY AT STONEMAN
DOUGLAS WAS NOT BECAUSE OF
STONEMAN DOUGLAS, WAS BECAUSE OF
PEOPLE LIKE NICHOLAS CRUZ WERE
ABLE TO BUY THESE WEAPONS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THE 17
BULLETS WE JUST TOOK TAKE US
DOWN.
IF ANYTHING WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
RUNNING AND LEAVE THEM A NEST OF
THE NATION BEHIND US.
>> Katie: MEANWHILE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS REPORTEDLY
MOVED BY THE SIGHT OF THE
VICTIMS DURING A VISIT TO THE
HOSPITAL ON FRIDAY AND DISCUSSED
GUN-CONTROL OPTIONS WITH FRIENDS
OVER THE WEEKEND.
THIS MORNING THE WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCED THE PRESIDENT SUPPORTS
LEGISLATION TO STRENGTHEN THE
FEDERAL BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM.
WHILE THE RELATIVE WAY MODEST,
IT COULD BE A SIGN OF MORE
AMBITIOUS GUN-CONTROL EFFORTS TO
COME.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH FORMER
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN JASON CHAFFETZ AND
ANTOINE.
JASON, YOU ARE IN CONGRESS FOR A
LONG TIME.
NOT TOO LONG, BUT LONG ENOUGH.
WHAT CAN YOU DO, IF ANYTHING, TO
MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN?
>> I WISH THERE WAS ONE THING WE
COULD DO TO MAKE SURE IT NEVER,
EVER HAPPENS AGAIN, BUT I DO
LIKE THIS IDEA ABOUT FIXING THE
NATIONAL BACKGROUND SYSTEM.
IF YOU GO TO THE WEBSITE YOU
WILL SEE THAT THE STUDENT SPORTS
FOUNDATION AND OTHER SUPPORT
THIS.
I SUPPORTED IT IN CONGRESS.
IT'S PASSED OUT OF THE HOUSE I
BELIEVE AND IT HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
IT MAKES SENSE.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN RIGHT AND
WRONG, AND THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO ACQUIRE A GUN.
I HAVE A GUN, I HAVE FIVE GUNS,
I HAVE A CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT.
I AM A MEMBER OF THE NRA, BUT
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T MAKE THESE
TYPES OF DECISIONS SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO ACCESS A GUN, AND WHEN
THIS GUY GETS KICKED OUT OF
SCHOOL, OBVIOUSLY HAS PROBLEMS,
THE POLICE COME TO HIS HOUSE 30
TIMES, THERE'S A PROBLEM IN HIM
ACCESSING A GUN.
>> Katie: JUST TO GIVE THE
VIEWERS IN THE AUDIENCE A LITTLE
MORE CONTEXT ON WHAT YOU ARE
DISCUSSING WITH THE PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY IT IS NOT REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW THAT STATES INPUT
MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS INTO THE
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM AND
ADJUDICATED OR COMMITTED
INDIVIDUALS CANNOT BUY A GUN.
IT IS PROHIBITED.
IT IS A QUESTION ON THE
BACKGROUND CHECK FORM WHEN YOU
PURCHASE THE GUN.
THIS LEGISLATION REQUIRES THAT
STATES DO THAT.
ANTOINE, YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT
TAKE.
YOU ARE GOING AFTER THE FIREARMS
RATHER THAN NECESSARILY A STATE
INPUTTING MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS.
WHY DO YOU THINK WE ARE IN THIS
POSITION AND IS BLAMING THE NRA
AND ACCUSING THEM OF BEING ON
THE SIDE OF MURDERERS REALLY
FORWARDING THIS CONVERSATION?
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHERE I AM.
I AM ON THE SIDE OF COMMON SENSE
GUN REFORM MEASURES BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN THE COUNTRY.
I HAVE ZERO CONFIDENCE IN THE
WASHINGTON, D.C.,'S
DYSFUNCTIONAL CITY TO GET THIS
DONE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO LEAN HEAVILY
ON LOCAL LEGISLATIVE BODIES AND
EVEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE HERE
IN COLUMBIA, SOUTH CAROLINA,
WHERE I'M FROM, WHERE THE MAYOR
AND THE CITY COUNCIL AND A VERY
UNIFIED WAY BANNED THE SELLING
OF BUMP STOCKS.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
KEEP IN MIND IT WAS THIS
PRESIDENT WHO SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO REVERSE A
DECISION THAT IMPLEMENTED BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF THOSE
WHO HAVE MENTAL ISSUES.
>> Katie: I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THAT UP BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT TRUE.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WAS
RESEND AN EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA THAT SAID THAT
SOCIAL SECURITY RECIPIENTS AND
VETERANS WHO WANTED SOMEONE TO
HELP THEM WITH THEIR FINANCES
WERE THEN DEEMED MENTALLY UNFIT
AND THEREFORE UNABLE TO PAST
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND THEIR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS WERE
TAKEN AWAY WITH DUE PROCESS.
TO SAY THAT HE TOOK SOMETHING
BACK THAT NOW ENABLES MENTALLY
ILL PEOPLE TO GET A GUN JUST
ISN'T TRUE.
JASON I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOU.
>> IT WAS A MEASURE.
>> Katie: WE HEARD A WHOLE LOT
ABOUT NEW GUN-CONTROL MEASURES
AND PEOPLE SAYING THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE OF MAKING SURE WE TAKE
CERTAIN KINDS OF FIREARMS OFF OF
THE STREETS.
THERE'S ALSO THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE ARGUMENT THAT WE HAVEN'T
HEARD AS MUCH ABOUT.
THERE ARE STUDENTS AND AT SCHOOL
WHO DON'T LIKE BEING SITTING
DUCKS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF TEACHERS
WHO ARE MEMBERS THE NRA.
THERE ARE A MEMBER OF NRA
MEMBERS WHO HAVE CHILDREN WHO GO
TO THE SCHOOLS WHO BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE SOFT TARGETS AND THAT
THINGS NEED TO BE CHANGED.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AROUND THE COUNTRY WHO
DECIDED TO ALLOW TEACHERS TO BE
ARMED INSIDE OF THEIR CLASSROOMS
ARMED INSIDE OF THEIR CLASSROOM
CLASSROOMS?
>> NO, LOOK.
YOU'VE GOT SOME TEACHERS THAT
CAN'T NEGOTIATE A BUNSEN BURNER,
SO IT'S NOT FOR EVERYBODY.
BUT I THINK THESE ARE SOFT
TARGETS.
YOU HAVE TO BE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN'T GET INTO THAT
SCHOOL IN THE FIRST PLACE.
ONE OF THE REPORTS WE HEARD OUT
OF FLORIDA IF THEY HAD SOME
BULLETPROOF GLASS OR SOME
HARDENED GLASS SO HE COULDN'T
ACTUALLY SHOOT OUT THE WINDOW
AND SHOOT AT THE STUDENTS THAT
WERE FLEEING, BUT YOU ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE A RESOURCE
OFFICER, MAYBE IT'S A POLICE
OFFICER WHO WAS ON DUTY OR OFF
DUTY WHO KNOWS HOW TO WIELD A
GUN AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
CERTAIN TEACHERS IN CERTAIN
PLACES SHOULD AND CAN BE
EQUIPPED.
THEY DO IT IN COLORADO, THEY DO
IT IN OTHER PLACES AND I THINK
IT'S A GOOD IDEA FOR A LOT OF
PLACES.
BY THE WAY, BALTIMORE, CHICAGO
AND WASHINGTON, D.C., --
>> HERE WE GO, JASON.
>> IT'S TRUE.
THEY HAVE SOME OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS WITH GUNS.
>> Katie: DO YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THAT?
IS THAT AN IRRELEVANT POINT?
IS THAT NOT A RELEVANT POINT TO
BRING UP AND THE FACT THAT
CHICAGO HAS HAD HUNDREDS OF
MURDERS IN 2017 AND YET IT'S NOT
IN THE HEADLINES EVERY DAY?
>> IT'S THE GO TO A PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE TALKING POINT.
>> Katie: IS IT NOT TRUE?
IS IT NOT TRUE?
>> IT'S TRUE.
IT'S THE GO TO REPUBLICAN PIVOT
POINT.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT REASONABLE
PEOPLE WANT.
THEY WANT TO NOT HAVE AK-47s
ON THE STREET, A 19-YEAR-OLD WHO
CAN'T RENT A CAR OR BUY WINE
SHOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO PURCHASE
AN AK 47.
REASONABLE PEOPLE WANT TO CLOSE
THE LOOPHOLE.
MY FRIEND WAS KILLED IN A CHURCH
HERE IN CHARLESTON,
SOUTH CAROLINA, SO THAT WILL NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN.
REASONABLE PEOPLE WANT TO BAN
BUMP STOCKS.
REASONABLE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
WANT TO DO INSTEAD OF THE
TRADITIONAL PIVOT TO TALK ABOUT
WALTER MOORE AND CHICAGO.
THE RED MEAT TALKING POINTS.
>> Katie: YOU TALK ABOUT IT
BEING UNREASONABLE.
IS IT UNREASONABLE TO THINK THAT
PLACES LIKE CHICAGO AND
BALTIMORE THAT HAVE ALL THE
GUN-CONTROL LEGISLATION YOU
COULD POSSIBLY ASK FOR WOULD NOT
BE THE EXAMPLES THAT WE SHOULD
FOLLOW CONSIDERING THEIR MURDER
RATES?
>> SURE.
HERE'S WHAT I WILL TELL YOU, I'M
NOT SEEING GUN CONTROL IS THE
ALL OUT FINAL ANSWER, BUT I
THINK IT WILL BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM IN THIS
COUNTRY TO PREVENT ANOTHER
CHARLESTON, TO PREVENT ANOTHER
NEW TOWN, TO PREVENT ANOTHER
PARKLAND, FLORIDA.
>> Katie: SOMETHING THAT
HASN'T WORKED, BUT JASON, LAST
WORD TO YOU.
>> I WOULD GET RID OF
BUMP STOCKS AS WELL.
THERE WAS A LOT OF EDUCATION
THAT NEEDS TO GO ON.
I OWN GUNS.
I HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
OWN GUNS.
>> ME TOO.
>> IF THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MENTALLY UNFIT -- THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE THEM AND IF
THEY RUN INTO TROUBLE THAN THEY
SHOULD TAKE THOSE GUNS AWAY.
THIS KID SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAD
IT AND THEY HAVE TO TIE THOSE
LIPS TOGETHER.
>> Katie: THANK YOU.
>> SO WE AGREED THAT WE DO NOT
NEED AK-47s ON THE STREET,